Thank you for sharing your responses. I will
be providing feedback on the discussion forums periodically. Now,
here's one way in which we can solve
this problem. We have to write a program that
somehow looks at the right folder and gets
for us all of the filenames from that folder.
So let me write this down. As the first step we have to get all the file names.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Once we have all of the file names, for each of the file name, what we want the
program to do is rename those files. So as a second
step, for each file, we want to rename it.
And by rename I mean remove all of the numbers from
the file name. Let's build this. I encourage you to follow along.